servus sgz willkommen zum lange
ersehnten 5k special
5 inso mit dabei habe ich heute den
krankhafter was geht und wie man heute
die 50 fragen die mir gestellt habt
wir legen einfach mal los ich habe diese
von der stoppuhr nebenbei aber die auch
ich bin der quizmaster ich lebe einfach
los wir haben ja 50 fragen durch zu
bringen was eine ganze menge ist und
deshalb die erste frage direkt von billy
nlp gehst du trainieren denn dein
stiernacken ist ja gut aufgebaut
ja ich wäre place where you read designs
leveling
ich glaube schon den ganzen tag in
unterhosen haus herum ist das normal
das ist absolut normal mit dieser etwas
mache ich auch immer auch in der
aufgaben öfters als ich denke und macht
mit machen wir sonst mit kroko kraft wo
kommen sich fürs poppen mögen
mister cool mit welchem aufnahmen dann
musst du wohnst du mit kranken in einem
hort schnell wohl nicht gerade in einem
haus ich nehme auch mit fraps und des
city in windows movie maker und hiermit
obs up silverado hd was würdest du tun
wenn abonnenten vor deiner tür stehen
und durchgehend klinge das video folge
verzweifelt und ich würde ausrasten und
aber nicht im positiven sinn also
klingeln ist halt schon penetrant und an
meiner eigenen haus durch meine
abonnenten wird wahrscheinlich eh nie
erfahren wo ich wohne aber dass du bist
zu krass also privatsphäre und
österreich nicht gutheißen
wahrscheinlich wegschicken müssen
willst du mal kinder
ja auf jeden fall dave seit wann spielst
du mz spiel minecraft seit dem dezember
es gibt also ganz lustiges video wohl
wir zusammen für meinen kanal eine
aufnahme stehen wo er das erste mal sg
spielt die ist echt cool geworden also
wahrscheinlich weil er sofort könnt ihr
mal nach suchen würden packt an die
beschreibung kann ich euch verlinkt in
der beschreibung
johannes krabbe wie lang ist dein penis
sc 3 1 81 millionen bananen man müsste
bananen an kiva place wie bist du auf
deinen namen gekommen
ich bin auf meinen namen wie können wir
hatten eigentlich dem namen der name der
komfort max das ist ein ganz ein alter
spitzen aber von max also krankhafter
für mich wenn ihre brüder wie ihr
vielleicht wisst es wird glaube ich
später noch gefragt werden und ja das
ist meine initialen die boden irgendwie
so verwurzelt und englisch ausgesprochen
da kam es heraus und ja das ist die
ganze geschichte richtig
ich könnte mich übrigens auch erkennen
also als hackl hacks bester mann
wann hast du geburtstag geburtstag las
ich glaube ich erst mal ein also aber er
weiß mittlerweile ein bisschen hast du
eine freundin
das kleinkraftrad eine freundin seien
aber nicht alle
erinnerst du dich noch ein erstes video
ja ja das war richtig gleich war erst
die erste folge von lost pages
da konnte ich gar nicht wie alt bist du
18 gutes sagen wusste nicht mehr was du
bist so cool gibt es irgendwann
dinosaurs pack zum download das weiß ich
noch nicht ich habe gehört dass es da
ist es vermuten er den außerdem verboten
die das nicht hochladen weil die rechte
bei snacks liegen
deshalb darf man sich selbst verändern
aber nicht mehr hoch laden weil man darf
zwecks und auch nicht selbst hochladen
sondern es darf nur von der offiziellen
seite herunter geladen werden
ich meine wer ihm macht es auch um den
jungs halt einfach nichts installation
suisse player de hast du mal eine
zahnspange geht fallen niemals und ich
hoffe ich muss auch nicht eine
zahnspange tragen also kein held jetzt
eine alle zahnspangen träger aber ich
finds halt nicht so ästhetisch und
deswegen bin ich ganz froh szene gerade
sind aber es könnte sein dass
verbraucher mister cool wie es einige
auf youtube bekommen wie bist du auf
dein name kommen kannst du mal mit dem
player spielmechanik shader weiß nicht
ob mein laptop das mitmacht kann
manchmal schaue nicht auf laptop und wie
bin ich mein name kommen ist beantwortet
worden
die erste frage wie seid ihr auf youtube
bekommen ich glaube bei uns war das
relativ ähnlich also eine kette ich bin
über konkrete draufgekommen und mein
bruder essays über mich drauf gekommen
genau alles dann konkreter hallo luca
alexis korner 03 aber eine frage in
welchem russland lebst du herzen
tt hendrik was hast du für ein pc q11
man glaube ich habe ein lenovo ideapad
75 mit 8gb rahmen aufgerüstet und 256 gb
ssd als haupt platte lange margot rpj
welchen youtube würdest du mal gerne auf
und ich glaube mit heißen glaube ich
auch mit welchem lügen
ich habe auf den dvd 2 muss kein geld
denn ich ganz cool sind akkurat größter
nicht weißt du das siehst und shuffle
den fand ich auch ganz nett mit denen
würde ich mal was starten in die bock
drauf habe mit update gibt sich
vielleicht was vielleicht etwas in
planung
red mit etwas mit aber can war ein geben
apa red
wisst ihr werdet sehen marco was
studierst du ich studiere kultur ein
kommunikations hersteller reihe oder tüv
der reihe kfz auf lehramt parallel dazu
kultur und kommunikationswissenschaften
mit schwerpunkt medienwissenschaften
aber ich bin gerade dabei zu
betriebswissenschaften also bwl zu
wechseln unterstrich seriös wie hast du
dein letzter umgebaut und wieviel fps
hast du mein kreuz ich habe einfach
irgendwas reinpacken lassen also mehr
arbeitsspeicher ddr3 8 gb ist bescheid
und eine ssd weil meine alte festplatte
ist aufnahme gelegt und ich habe 60 fps
minecraft aber ich glaube dass es ewig
easing also über monitor beschränkt ich
könnte sich am meer
alessandro hallo was für musik fährst du
wo ich war mega viel musik aber mein
aktuelles lieblingsgerät berät ist
gerade die sympathie von metric
vielleicht verlängere ich euch das auch
mal welche machen da unten
ansonsten habe ich so nah wie diesmal
schön wird jack johnson auch ich glaube
die lieblings jetzt ein gehört gab es
noch nicht angehört muss man machen aber
ich kriege immer kurz meine sporty fall
ist natürlich für euch ich habe auch
schon ein video gemacht
schon ein video gemacht einfach mal
schauen auf einem kanal videos und
suchen meine musik damit müsste jedes
finden ich halt mit blabla ihr genetik
billy talent und so weiter und so weiter
paul kalkbrenner auch und er ist auch
bester r versuchen das ist richtig
geilen dass ich okay
wie heißt du im rila wissen
hab kreft sambi cvp aber hart
die schlawiner du meine frage nicht
warum hast du mich gekillt und einer
perfekten aufnahme bitten musste ich
muss irgendwas zu weil games ist nun
erkennt man ist krankhaft ein echter
bruder ja ein richtiger brüssel war
diesmal richtige wurde
xd frage kannst du deine texte nicht
dabei schob ersatz socken mit herbst
würdest du mit herbst mit herz würdest
du mit youtube aufnehmen die zehn bis
hundert abos abend wenn sie ein gutes
kanal konzept bieten hast du das gegen
youtube mit kindlichen stimmen müsste
man mit abonnenten in einem t es so was
wie ein interview machen nichts gegen
kenntnis stimmen interview habe ich
schon mal gemacht und erstes 10 bis 100
abonnenten
ja klar ich mein wenn wenn die leute mir
mega sympathisch sind und auch gute
sachen liefern soll ich sagen kann
es ziehe sich meine videos herunter dass
die in meinen videos sind damit nicht
machen klar sache ist hat die meisten
sind die leute mit die jetzt so weniger
abonnenten haben auch jetzt nicht so
mega gut von der quali er ja weil man
das ist kann man auf youtube zu sagen
wenn man auf youtube standhaft sachen
seine sache durchzieht und zeit
investiert danach noch gute videos und
dann wird man automatisch groß
irgendwann wird man groß ist schon indiz
dafür dass man nicht so die super
qualität hat wenn man
kleiner youtube ist das ist jetzt
motivation war weil selbst gestaltete
pushten gutes equipment macht noch
keinen guten display
goodgame hd wie kamst du zu minecraft
bzw
pc spiele pc spiele weil ich schon immer
geil angefangen
der us sender rias damals mit acht
jahren schon mein vater das mir gekauft
hat und ja minecraft rasch beseitigt als
andres zwei mal geil alter er das war
bei uns generell immer so sp hat gezockt
und ich stand blieben dran und hat
zugestimmt
ja das war immer so oft nur ein
richtiger sich immer selbst gezogen ist
das programm also rändern tut er mit
zitrone melone presse aufnahmen mit
flashforward frames bist du auch auf dem
video day oder wenn überhaupt auf der
gamescom video.de ist glaube ich keine
ahnung irgendein tag auf der gamescom
gamescom habe ich richtig bock
hinzugehen
wir sind nämlich kurz davor im urlaub
mit con crafter zusammen also beide und
er und dann vielleicht gibt sich da
lassen wir fahren einfach zusammen dahin
oder aber richtig bock auf gamescom
mache auf jeden fall
das war übrigens die die auch hier bei
uns ja ich weiß ja von einem dich
diamant crafter magst du komme hdd
minecraft freund für mich richtig toll
wie ich die ich gut mit kaviza nichts zu
tun gehabt macht gute videos so leider
nicht rap ist alles zu filtern
damon erstens wie kanton
warum ist ein skin schwarz neue race ist
was wir lustiges gehen und man kann so
was du findest also schwarze lustig was
races camps ursachen aber er hat so sp
wollte ich so dieses ganze gerne auf
lustig
wir haben übrigens von elf minuten ich
dafür machen wirklich zwei pars und
vielfach noch zehn dollar bekommst du
hast du da machst du eine
facebook-gruppe warum die
facebook-gruppe hertefeld welt und die
hat bisher gleich zehn dax oder so ich
habe keine nach vorbei also wie immer in
der beschreibung und klickt die facebook
fanpage die facebook fanpage und lassen
daumen nach oben da weil bei 10 likes
hab jetzt keine motivation etwas zu
machen mich nur auf twitter aktiv als
sie auf facebook was sehen wollt dann
bleibt die page und die power okay was
special mit der skizze des g 7
also sagten wir zocken und mit
überzeugung es kann nicht beantworten
mein bruder spielt so oft mit abonnenten
einfach mal im schreiben oder auf dem
safestick br seien sehr berühmt oder so
er spielt echt auf mehr ja das stimmt
auf jeden fall mal wo kannst du dir eine
dreiecksbeziehung vorstellen ja mit
karascada lario von skins falls er die
kennt und günther jauch mit dem ball
da ich bock drauf und holte den gamer pc
mal schauen die kosten 1000 euro das ist
halt eine investition ein bisschen eine
ältere youtube machst du wenn ja wie
hast du sie gesagt
wissen sie und wird gesagt ich habe bock
das zu machen
mir gefällt das wie max das macht und
ich will dass selbst aufmachen und eben
gesagt nicht so einfach
einfach gesagt ich will das machen indem
er so braun ja unsere eltern sind schon
kritisch denkenden bullshit aber geil
und es unser hobby das müssen aspekt
ihren also durchsetzen
das ist eine rhetorische frage klar die
antwort ist ja nett peet glaubst du bist
besser als maxime pvp natürlich glaubst
du bist besser als maxi pvp darauf mit
max zu entpuppen schon richtig
bescheuert jako-arena abgebrochen
unterschiedlich wissen glaube ich
ziemlich auf einem level mit dem bogen
smax ein bisschen besser wollten den
bogen richtig krass verbessert habt muss
jetzt sagen ohne mich selbst zu pushen
opfer aber ich glaube mit dem schwert
kenne ich ihn noch obwohl ein bisschen
besser und pink
reiko case love 34
wie groß bist du 1 meter 90 191 ersten
big boss der zocker apps willst du so
bleiben wenn du mehr abos hast oder
willst du anders nee ich habe bock
richtiges arschloch zu werben ist mein
plan
jeanette schon wieder dieser aufwand
denkst die zusammen mit dem stück kommt
der erste live stream im sommer das
hängt alles davon ab weil ich nach hause
gehe zu gerade nächste woche vielleicht
nächste woche ist hängt alles davon ab
wann ich erst mal nach hause schau
damals direkten leistungsversprechen
markus betz auch offline nehmen sollte
ich weiß ja mit offline mein single
player mache ich nie habe ich früher
immer gemacht um so ein bisschen
reinzukommen aber eigentlich überhaupt
nicht mehr letzte frage auch wieder von
markus b
was hast du für einen pc wurde schon
geantwortet deshalb ist eine letzte
frage und die improvisiere eine letzte
frage wirst du dir mit krankhafter
zusammen eine gopro für den berlin
urlaub kaufen mit dem er coole videos
machen werdet und wieder leute da kommt
einiges auf mich zu nicht nur auf diesem
kanal wo ich bald neue serie bringen
und sondern auch stichwort berlin
man munkelt dass er weiß da ist man nur
für das max am start ist es sich im
stadt und das sind pro da irgendwie so
ein dickes brot haben ein bisschen rum
klose gibt es terrassentür für maniche
und youtube money und daran aufnehmen
es wird glaube ich richtig geil also ich
würde sagen das werden wahrscheinlich
die geilsten gopro aufnahmen die jemals
die minecraft szene gesehen hat oder man
so von der jungen bisher finde ich schon
auf jeden fall leute wenn euch das video
gefallen hat das einen daumen nach oben
da dieses 5k special hat mir richtig
spaß gemacht so ein bisschen was zu
erzählen ich glaube ich auch und checkt
max ab dessen beschreibung die anderen
links die ich da rein gepackt habe beim
nächsten video wieder haut 32